you
alright so as waging said I'm Jennifer
Wong and I'm here to talk about
designing responsive emails and coding
in the year 2000 and you all are welcome
to follow along by going to this github
link here and to start so Who am I I am
a software engineer at eventbrite and
before that I actually worked as a civil
engineer just like these two ladies here
I quickly became bored with the very
slow pace of the projects at that time
you know things when you're making
buildings it takes years to complete so
I wanted to be in a more innovative
space and I decided that that would be
tech so to get my foot in the door I
started doing I started working as a
community specialist for a startup and
that meant that I was actually just
doing customer support for a company
that was around for about 10 years I
totally totally hated it and so I
decided to teach myself to code I would
work on my projects at nights I would go
to hack my hackathons and I just kept
working on these things and eventually
that led to success and I landed my
first job as a front-end developer at a
company called hot pads yay so here we
go my first assignment at hot pads was
to redesign all of our emails and make
them responsive and I was like oh yeah
no problem super easy right I started
working them on those emails and I
thought oh crap I have no idea what I'm
doing but fortunately i'm here to share
all of my strategies and mistakes with
you all so my story is about how emails
are evil which I'm sure many of you can
relate to if you've ever worked on
responsive emails so I'll talk a bit
about design
food and I'll share some resources that
i found along the way so to start I'm
going to talk about design so first
things first when I was working on
hotpads they asked me to redesign their
welcome email and i decided to first
start by doing a bunch of research so i
signed up for a ton of different
services just so i could look at their
welcome emails I thought the prettiest
email that i found was actually in d
gogos which we can take a look at here
very quickly oh there we go so the first
thing I notice about this email is they
have this top anchored logo so you know
exactly where the emails coming from and
as they move down the page I see a lot
of really beautiful image content and
notice that all their calls to action
are the same color so I can just click
on these buttons on these pink links and
also i can click on the images which is
great so keep scrolling down and then I
also notice that there they have these
social media buttons but also they have
links in text and that's really great
for accessibility and then I also see of
course a way to unsubscribe and update
your subscription so some of the
takeaways that I found in doing all the
research and again I received many many
welcome emails was that most of them
were very text light many of them were
very image heavy there was always a logo
there at the very top of the email and
also max-width so you didn't have your
users reading across the page a quick
disclaimer about all those things so
they may not work for everybody and I
highly recommend if you're working on
emails is to a/b tests all of your
emails so after doing that research I
decided to check out what our welcome
email looked like get ready
this is what it looked like the first
thing I notice I'm like why is our logo
kind of right in the middle of our email
what's with all that weird spacing and
why is there text after our closing for
like welcome on board but then we add on
a bunch of stuff at the end and then
there's also no way to unsubscribe so
seeing that email I felt very much like
Doge was like wow just wow all right so
next up I decided to plan and I was like
what am I making what am i doing for hot
pads so I had a couple of goals and
those two things were to bring
consistency to our emails our emails
were just all over the place they all
look different they all looked crazy so
I wanted to really give them a more
formalized template and I thought that
that would bring a lot of brand
awareness because once you see that
recognizable template you know where
your emails are coming from so to make
or not to make I decided or I checked
out the internet and saw that there are
a ton of pre-made email templates that
you can use so you don't actually have
to build them from scratch and they can
be quite helpful but I actually didn't
use them personally and there are a few
reasons for that those reasons being
that it was my first project as a
front-end developer and I really wanted
to get you know in the nitty-gritty of
the code and so I actually built up our
template from scratch if you guys have
less time to work on your emails
pre-made templates can be a really great
way to go on when designing emails it
can be really great to sketch so here
you can see I've sketched the same email
four different times and that just gives
you a sense of where you want to lay
things out and that can really help
before your coding especially if you
don't have a designer Photoshop can be
really great if you have the skills I
definitely say go for it
another thing I wanted to think about
when I was planning was what I call our
role of thumbs or the minimum touchable
area on mobile devices so I had often
heard of the number 44 x 44 pixels it
turns out that number is wrong it comes
from the original iphone human interface
guidelines for the very first iphone and
those guidelines don't even exist
anymore so just so you know actually all
mobile devices have a different minimum
touchable area so i've linked to these
two pages here and they definitely help
you figure out what that size is and
it's really dependent on what devices
are most popular with your users so here
is the new template for our welcome
email that I created I like to say it's
a design for the new millennium in the
year 2000 so the design I can see is
like a little bit outdated but this is
actually what our website looks like
back then and so I was obviously pulling
some design cues from our website and
just for comparison this is what our old
emails look like and versus the new one
all right on to some code so here's a
bunch of tips and tricks that I learned
along the way so some things that I
learned before I started coding our
emails number one tables are coming
mozilla developers network says note
prior to the creation of CSS HTML table
elements were often used as a message
for page layout this usage has been
discouraged since HTML 4 and the table
element should not be used for layout
purposes email say Lowell
tables are really important in emails if
you don't have a rapper table in your
email it actually makes all of your code
disappear in Apple Mail and outlook 2011
so make sure you have that outer table
something I also found out was that
tables don't display as inline or block
or inline block and I was like what what
does that mean well table is actually
default to display as table but in that
case chrome actually will ignore a max
wits that you said on your emails so you
definitely want to set your table to
display as block next up is inline
styles you definitely need them reason
being gmail doesn't support of style on
the head outlook.com doesn't support a
link element in the head and many
clients don't support a whole like bevy
and slew of CSS so a really great page
to help you know what is supported is
campaign monitor CSS page here what you
see here is a really great chart which
shows all of these different email
clients and what's supported what CSS is
supported in them so unfortunately
you're going to be doing a whole lot of
this if you're designing emails it's
really ugly I know but it's got to
happen all right again back to max width
so I think that this company didn't get
the memo on max width and you see that
their text just kind of goes all the way
across the screen and it just makes it
really hard to read so it's important to
set a max width on your email and
typically it's between 550 to 600 pixels
and that's based on most email clients
preview pains a quick note about
comments when you're writing emails
you're going to have tables within
tables within tables and so you're going
to have tables all the way down your
page and it's really important to have
comments so you know where you are so if
you go back and look at this code really
quickly you'll see that it's great and
super helpful to have comments letting
you know where each table begins and
all right image alternatives it's always
great to have an alt tag or a background
color on your images a lot of browsers
and clients don't automatically display
images and so when that happens it's
good to have a back up there and this is
also great for accessibility so you
should be doing it on the web as well so
this is an example of an email in Gmail
our logo didn't show up and so it's
great to have that alts there so that
your users know what image is being
loaded another thing I did is in our
footer we had that really beautiful like
image at the very bottom but I set a
background color on that so that the
border goes all the way around in case
that images and showing and I created a
template you can check it out on github
why should you template well it's really
great to not have to repeat yourself so
here you see two different emails but
all those little micro listings you'll
see they overlap between both and so
those are just kind of little pieces of
abstracted code that I don't have to
keep riding over and over again so it's
really helpful to have a template all
right some things I learned while I was
coding my emails media queries I'm sure
you guys are all really familiar with
those they can be super helpful for
readability and also targeting specific
devices a quick note is that there are a
lot of clients that don't support media
queries so you'll definitely want to pay
attention to those and style campaign
did a really great or did some really
great research on this and so they tell
you which devices and which email
clients will support media queries or
not and with media queries you
definitely want to cover your bases so
it's really good to use them in
conjunction with fluid layouts so here
I've paired a media query targeting
devices that are smaller with the
percentage based width here and that
will help you cover all the clients that
do and don't support media queries next
up is device pixel ratio so the device
pixel ratio is the ratio between logical
pixels and physical pixels and that will
help you target retina or high res
devices and I'll actually come to a
really great example of that in just a
bit all right important when should you
use it a lot of people say never but in
emails it can be necessary sometimes in
emails your inline styles will overwrite
media queries so here's a really good
example of when you actually want to use
important so in line I have the height
and the line height of an element set to
10 pixels but on actually smaller
devices what I want is to have a height
and the line height be 5 pixels and so I
have to set an important on there when
being used with a media query all right
something weird I learned along the way
to is about line height if you look at
the very bottom of this image you'll see
this like thin blue line right at the
bottom and I'm like what is that oh why
is that there it's so annoying it turns
out that the solution to this is to set
a line height on the surrounding column
element of your image and that just
brings it down all right some things I
learned after the release of my emails
oops this one is really weird when you
have an image tag in an anchor tag
something strange happens sometimes in a
client you'll see that there's this
weird gray border around your image and
it's so it happens so occasionally and
so strangely that I don't even have an
example of it unfortunately it turns out
the reason for this is actually the
white space in your HTML and so you can
actually just move the image tag to be
in the same line as your anchor tag or
you can comment out the white space and
that removed that weird gray border
hi-res images for retina
so this email actually went out to a
bunch of our users and they're like what
oh my god caution has like oh crap I'm
sorry so what was the problem here the
problem was I was using a very large
image and then sizing it down for retina
devices but outlook 2007 2010-2013 and
outlook and Internet Explorer don't
allow for HTML or css image resizing the
solution is to set a background image
your retina image on the surrounding
column element and then set the inner
image to display as none and i found
that solution on campaign monitor so
here you'll see that's exactly what i've
done so i set a background image on our
column element and then the image inside
the column element i set to display as
none so that's how you can use retina
images in your emails um another thing
is that outlook 2007 2010 and 2013 don't
support max width so what you'll want to
do here is use a max with bypass what
you do is you set a fluid layout as your
baseline so you set that to be your
woods one hundred percent so that all
use cases use that one hundred percent
but for larger screens then you'll set
the width to be affixed with instead of
using max width so you may be wondering
outlook 2007 2010 in 2013 WTF well the
reason for their issues is the rendering
engines outlook 2002 2003 use Internet
Explorer to render their emails outlook
2007 10 and 13 used Microsoft Word as
their rendering engines and I'm sure you
guys can understand what problems that
would cause outlook 2011 also called
outlook for mac actually uses webkit to
render their emails and I was like why
did you guys switch back to Microsoft
Word in 2013 I don't know but that's
something to keep in mind
again gmail doesn't support styles in
the head so if you want to change the
color of your links you actually have to
go and style every single anchor tag in
line of your email so definitely think
twice before you decide to change that
color AOL and outlook.com they do these
this really weird thing well the they'll
prefix all of your styles and your
classes with either external class or
ale AOL replaced body a solution to that
for at least outlook calm is you can
actually prefix all your classes
yourself which is great you can just
target them right away but AOL you can't
do that because it'll double up the
class and that'll target nothing so I
found out that actually a well does
support Unicode classes though but not
Unicode IDs and so that's a really great
way to target AOL styles and that's
something that I learned from mr. mark
Robbins unfortunately android mail and
outlook.com in internet explorer also
support the Unicode class but not the
Unicode ID so targeting AOL it
specifically is probably not possible at
least in what I found but if anybody
else knows of anything definitely let me
know Yahoo argh they really like to
strip out a bunch of things so they'll
strip out your overflow X property
they'll strip out any importance that
you have and strangely they'll strip out
a display none in line but not in your
style block something to keep in mind at
WebKit WebKit and opera do not mask on
your border radius so you see here in
this image on the left you can see that
that little border radius in grey
there's a little its kind of blocked
there's like a little corner missing
there I can't see my borderie yes and
then what I wanted it to show up like is
on
right I wanted to see that border-radius
there so what you can do to solve that
issue if you guys are received at your
border radius is missing is that you can
add an intermediate div that doesn't
have the CSS positioning on your board
or a radius Oh or the overflow hidden so
that's this is what that looks like so
the parent element is positioned the
intermediate element has the border
radius and the overflow hidden and
that's the one that's not positioned and
that's what will allow your border
radius to appear alright shhh ain't
changes so android gmail allows you to
use forms prior to version 5.0 but
android gmail disabled that after
android or after version 5.0 however
android email does support forums so
basically you just have to keep rolling
with the times we really wanted to use
forums and you just have to keep doing
research on what you can do to make that
happen so you have to stay up to date
and you can stay up to date by checking
out a bunch of these resources that I
found first up there's a bunch of blogs
here style campaign is a great service
that is run by a woman named Anna Yeaman
she's a creative director there and she
has a bunch of really amazing solutions
she has this crazy device lab you can
kind of see it in the background here
and she has tons of devices that she's
constantly testing on litmus is a really
great email testing suite and they allow
you to test your emails across many
different clients campaign monitor and
MailChimp are both online marketing
email solutions and they allow you to
send emails check out analytics and test
your emails use different templates so
these are all really amazing blogs
they're just working with emails all day
and I found a lot of great information
on those templates so earlier I
mentioned that there are a bunch of
pre-made templates that you can use
and so here are a bunch of them in the
background you'll actually see the HTML
email boilerplate it's a lot of code
it's really crazy but of course it's
going to most likely really hit all
those email clients that you may need to
support so go ahead and check those out
and lastly for resources oops come on
keyboard testing testing your emails is
super important people are reading
emails on all types of devices in all
types of clients all the time so a bunch
of resources here but litmus email and
acid and targeted i/o are really great
solutions they they support a ton of
different clients and puts mail actually
is a free service and that can be really
helpful as well and that's all i have
for you if you have questions feel free
to find me after the talk there are some
pseudo cast in CSS by however oh haha
are they working on the those kinds so
you can actually check out that campaign
monitor CSS page and it'll tell you
there are some pseudo classes that are
supported and some that are not and it
really depends on the client how do you
deal with the consistency of once on of
course i'll email clients that are
concerned i do america I it email HTML
email as well and my main problem is the
font I think custom fonts are not
supported on me aside how do you make
the funds consistent on all the
immigrants use a standard font I think
that's probably your best solution
unfortunately is to really have just the
standard fonts or if you want to use a
custom font to use it just on the
clients that support it and definitely
have like a very
you know sturdy fall back in that case
if there any way to bypass the image
display permissions in outlook like when
you first open the mail and outlook you
have to like click right click and give
the permission or display is there any
way to bypass that I don't think there's
a way to do that unfortunately it has to
come from the user or consumer side